aber damit dass wir zum nächsten
einziges ladegerät tag der
haushaltsberatung und der einzelplan
justiz der steht jetzt als nächstes hier
auf dem board auf der tagesordnung und
die rechtspolitiker die
haushaltspolitiker sich sicherlich schon
mal hier in die ersten reihen und wir
erwarten natürlich hier als erster den
zuständigen minister zu seinem etat das
ist marco buschmann
[Applaus]
braucht präsidentin sehr geehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen liebe
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
einigkeit
und recht und freiheit nicht zum ersten
mal zitiere ich hier unsere hymne denn
das alte lied der deutschen beschreibt
noch immer werte die auch für die
moderne liberale demokratie
unersetzlich sind und diese werte sind
einer schlimmen kraftprobe ausgesetzt
putin hat ihnen in der ukraine
militärisch den kampf angesagt und seit
dieser woche wissen wir dass putin der
einigkeit
dem recht und der freiheit deutschlands
den wirtschaftlichen kampf angesagt hat
denn putins regierung hat nun auch
offiziell die energielieferung zum
politischen kampf instrument erklärt die
bundesregierung ist sich bewusst dass
diese kampfansage mit schweren
belastungen für viele menschen und
betriebe in unserem lande verbunden ist
wir werden nicht jede dieser belastungen
ausgleichen können aber die tatsache
dass wir mit den drei entlastungspaket
mittlerweile fast 100 milliarden euro
mobilisiert haben um zu helfen zeigt
dass uns die soziale einheit unseres
landes viel wert ist meine damen und
recht
und freiheit sind die hauptaufgaben
meines hauses viele beobachter konnten
erkennen dass wir hier bereits große
anstrengungen unternommen haben der
staatsrechtler oliver lepsius erklärte
jüngst in der tageszeitung die welt dass
etwa die korona politik mit dem
regierungswechsel
deutlich transparenter verhältnismäßiger
und stärker an den grundrechten
orientiert erfolgen würde das ist ein
fortschritt war recht und freiheit meine
damen und herren
die süddeutsche zeitung
schrieb vor einigen wochen über die
vielen initiativen im bereich der
familiengesellschaft oder auch
strafrechts politik dass man eben in der
rechtspolitik zitat den
gesellschaftspolitischen sound zitat
ende der neuen regierung deutlich mit
präge ich glaube das ist ein fortschritt
war recht und freiheit meine damen haben
und als erstes haus hat das
bundesministerium der justiz ein
gesetzentwurf zur planungs
beschleunigung vorgelegt mit einer
reform der verwaltungsgerichtsordnung
leisten wir unseren beitrag dass es
jetzt mit den wichtigen großprojekten
bei den verwaltungsgerichten schneller
vorangeht das ist ein fortschritt im
recht und angesichts der bedeutung einer
neuen energie infrastruktur die uns
unabhängig von putin macht auch ein
beitrag zur freiheit meine sehr geehrten
damen kann
wir erledigen diese aufgaben sehr
kostengünstig denn für diesen entwurf
des einzelplatz meines hauses gilt wir
geben weniger als eine milliarde euro
aus und wir erwirtschaften fast 70
prozent davon durch eigene einnahmen das
ist ein kosten nutzen verhältnis glaube
ich dass ich sehen kann meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren
die summe der ausgaben ist klein
trotzdem ist die sorgfalt im umgang mit
dem steuerzahler geld gleichwohl groß
das hat uns übrigens der
bundesrechnungshof bestätigt in diesem
jahr gab es zum entwurf des einzelplan 7
keine einzige beanstandung und auch dass
es eine gute nachricht man damen und
herren
trotzdem haben die gestalterische und
politische schwerpunkte gesetzt die sich
auch in diesem entwurf niederschlagen
die finanzierung der überwachungs
gesamtrechnung ist geregelt die stiftung
datenschutz hat wieder eine perspektive
um besser arbeiten zu können und auch
die weitere digitalisierung der justiz
ist sichergestellt wir entwickeln
gemeinsam mit den ländern und den
bundesgerichten ein
bundeseinheitliches system für video
verhandlungen wir haben begonnen ein
zivilgericht liches online verfahren zu
entwickeln und wir arbeiten ein
digitalen rechtsantragsstelle für die
digitale erfassung von anliegen und
anträgen bei gerichten auch für die
justiz gilt also wir wollen mehr
fortschritt wagen
ansonsten werden wir rechtspolitisch
auch nicht müde werden bald endlich und
das sage ich aus gegebenem anlass an
dieser stelle die anlasslose
vorratsdatenspeicherung
beenden endlich meine damen und
wir werden in der gesellschaftspolitik
im strafrecht stichwort halbierung der
ersatzfreiheitsstrafe im namensrecht und
vor allem im familienrecht auch in den
kommenden monaten daran arbeiten das
recht endlich auf die höhe der
gesellschaftlichen wirklichkeit zu
bringen
das stärkt im übrigen auch die justiz
der länder denn die länder werden allein
durch die reform der
ersatzfreiheitsstrafe
voraussichtlich über 60 millionen euro
im jahr sparen auf den zeitraum einer
legislaturperiode gerechnet ist es
übrigens mehr als der alte pakt für den
rechtsstaat bewegt hat und es ist vor
allen dingen eine entlastung die für
immer bleibt keine anschubfinanzierung
entlastung die für immer bleibt und ich
gehen natürlich davon aus dass jeder
gesparte euro im system der justiz
verbleibt und
umher auch dieses thema zu erwähnen
natürlich bleibt meine hand weiter
ausgestreckt
um mit den ländern über die
ausgestaltung einer weiteren förderung
der landesjustizminister bundes zu
sprechen das tun sie auf arbeitsebene
übrigens schon seit märz diesen jahres
und egal worauf wir uns einigen eines
ist mir dabei wichtig das geld muss
zusätzlich investiert werden es muss in
der justiz bleiben und es muss dazu
beitragen dass wir eine modernere
digitale justiz bekommen meine damen und
herren ich komme zum schluss
einigkeit
und recht und freiheit
das ist unser leitstern in dunkler zeit
dem fühlen wir uns verpflichtet
und dem dient dieser haushaltsentwurf
ich freue mich auf konstruktive
beratungen darüber
sagt bundesjustizminister marco
buschmann hier zum auftakt der
beratungen seines etats er hat auch zu
einigen aktuell noch hinweise gegeben
beispielsweise stichwort pakt für den
rechtsstaat sein forlán drängen die
bundesländer auf geld vom bund für mehr
personal in der justiz das
spitzentreffen das soll nun den
durchbruch bringen und ist für den 16
september in berlin geplant der
bundesminister sehr geehrte damen und
herren liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
der haushalt des
bundesjustizministeriums ist es der
kleinste einzelplan aber er ist nicht
minder wichtig denn das
justizministerium ist auch der garant
für den schutz unseres rechtsstaates und
unsere grundrechte die gesamtausgaben
für 20 23 sind angesetzt mit c a 954
millionen euro und das sind 15 4
millionen euro oder 16 prozent mehr als
in diesem jahr ein besonderer einsatz
des justizministers für diesen haushalt
lässt sich allerdings mit den zahlen
nicht verbinden sie haben zu unserer
kritik an der personalausstattung des
generalbundesanwalt es aufgegriffen und
haben die mittelkürzung aus 2022 in 22
23 wieder rückgängig gemacht aber in
ihrem haushalt fehlen die mittel für
einen digital packt es fehlen die mittel
für die fortsetzung des paktes für den
rechtsstaat und die inflation die in
diesem mit acht prozent an schlägt im
nächsten jahr mit 8 prozent zuschlägt
ist im haushalt nicht berücksichtigt
dass der etat fing der etat sinkt in
allen ansätzen faktisch und das ist
gerade in diesen zeiten ein fehler das
gilt im übrigen auch für die stiftungen
die unterstützt werden ebenso wie die
tatsache dass auch möglich beim personal
mögliche erhöhungen nicht berücksichtigt
sind sie haben sich für den für das
gesetz zur plan beschleunigung gelobt ja
das ist gut dass wir hier ein
beschleunigungsgesetz auf den weg
gebracht habe oder dass sie es auf den
weg gebracht haben aber wo sie keinen
schritt vorangekommen sind was nicht
minder wichtig ist ist der pakt für den
rechtsstaat und der digital fakt die fdp
lieber herr kollege buschmann bezeichnet
sich gerne als digital partei aber
leider haben sie hier in diesem bereich
in der zeit seit sie diese ministerium
vor stehen mit den ländern keine einzige
lösung und kein einzige fortschritt
herbeigeführt es reicht nicht aus sich
mit den ländern nur auszutauschen sie
befinden sich mit den ländern und allen
fraktionen in eine dauer
auseinandersetzung und deshalb steht
nächste woche auch der nächste
krisengipfel an und beim thema
digitalisierung liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen von der fdp lieber herr
buschmann kann man hier wahrlich nicht
von einem fortschritt sprechen sie haben
es nicht geschafft einen digitalen
ministerium an dieser ampel
durchzusetzen und sie haben es bis jetzt
nicht mehr geschafft als ein
eckpunktepapier zur digitalisierung
vorzulegen ende august ist erstmal
nichts anderes enthält als
zuständigkeiten zu beschreiben
die fdp liebe kolleginnen kollegen
bezeichnet sich eben auch gerne als
rechtsstaatspartei der rechtsstaat
existiert aber nicht einfach so die
bürgerinnen und bürger
die länder sie müssen darauf vertrauen
können dass er funktioniert und das
gemachte zusagen eingehalten werden
gemachte zusagen müssen eingehalten
werden dafür braucht man um diese rechte
durchsetzen zu können genügend personal
und die länder fordern daher auch zu
recht dass der in der letzten
legislaturperiode vereinbarte und
erfolgreiche pakt für den rechtsstaat
als pakt für den rechtsstaat 2.0 auch
wie versprochen weitergeführt wird es
muss wie immer noch in deutschland im
schnitt eindringen ein dringend
tatverdächtiger pro woche aus der
untersuchungshaft entlassen werden weil
die gerichte überlastet und die
strafverfahren zu lange dauern dass nach
darf nicht sein wir haben das in der
letzten legislaturperiode angepackt
gemeinsam mit den ländern sie haben im
koalitionsvertrag versprochen es
fortzusetzen und sie halten wäre
versprechen schlicht und ergreifend
nicht ein
den rechtsstaat liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen den digitalen rechtsstaat den
gibt es nicht zum nulltarif und deswegen
fordern wir sie auf mit den ländern
gemeinsam mit dem rechtsstaat 2.0
fortzusetzen und einen digital pakt für
die justiz abzuschließen sie haben ja
nächste woche beim krisengipfel mit den
ländern die chance dazu
es ist aber nicht nur erforderlich dass
ausreichend finanzielle mittel zur
verfügung stehen wichtig sind auch
richtige thematische
schwerpunktsetzungen mit vor allen
dingen den richtigen prioritäten
hier setzten sie oft auf die falschen
prioritäten und das möchte ich ihnen an
einem punkt ganz gerne erläutern sie
haben mit wirklich großen tamtam hier im
haus im frühjahr als erstes großes
projekt das verbot der werbung für
schwangerschaft ab schwangerschafts
abbrüche den paragrafen 219 a stgb
abgeschafft sie haben sich dafür auf die
schulter geklopft deshalb erst aber
gewesen sie hätten einen vorschlag zur
speicherung von ip-adressen vorgelegt um
die fast 14 millionen kinder und
jugendlichen in deutschland besser vor
sexueller gewalt und kinderpornographie
zu schützen allein schon an ihren
zwischenrufen lässt sich erkennen wie
wenig wichtig ihnen dieses thema ist
leider
ip adressen sind nämlich oft der einzige
hinweis auf die täter und das wird ihnen
jeder ermittler bestätigen der bh hat
die speicherung schon im oktober 2020
für zulässig erklärt und liebe spd ihre
innenministerin hat es mittlerweile auch
verstanden und sie es auch dafür was den
betroffenen aber nichts nützt ist die
uneinigkeit der ampel die uneinigkeit
zwischen ein buschmann und frau fischer
deshalb herr buschmann verabschieden sie
sich endlich von ihrer placebo lösung
wie quick freeze und handeln sie endlich
im interesse der kinder und
auch dem vorschlag der europäischen
kommission eine verordnung zur
verhinderung und bekämpfung von
sexuellem kindesmissbrauch
lassen sie wahrlich jedes positive
engagement vermissen man muss nicht mit
allem einverstanden sein was die
kommission vorschlägt aber dass man von
ihnen wieder nur skepsis und ablehnung
vernimmt das reiht sich ein in ihre
bisherige politik natürlich dürfen
digitale bürgerrechte keine rechte
zweiter klasse sein aber es reicht
niemals ein dass es mir nicht minister
nicht aus hier allgemein bedenken zu
äußern
es geht darum sich aktiv gedanken zu
machen und lösungen zu finden wie man
kinderpornografie in sozialen netzwerken
und auf plattformen besser bekämpft wie
man mit klaren rechtsgrundlagen mit
verbindlichen meldewege und einem neuen
eu zentrum prävention und
strafverfolgung zum beispiel bei bereits
bekannten
kinderpornografischen bildern ermöglicht
und ich sage ihnen in diesem haus einst
die schwächsten in unserer gesellschaft
unsere kinder vor diesen widerlichen
verbrechen zu schützen auch und gerade
im digitalen bereich das muss unsere
aufgabe sein das muss uns eine vor
dringliche aufgabe sein
gestatten sie mir zu guter letzt auch
noch eine abschließende merkt bemerkung
zu den heute beschlossenen änderungen
des infektionsschutzgesetzes
sie haben sich ja immer so für ihre
fortschrittliche politik gerühmt gerade
auch im digitalbereich sie haben es aber
verpasst in den letzten monaten die
chance für eine fortschrittliche die die
chance an einer fortschrittlichen
pandemie politik mitzuarbeiten und
wirkliche weichen zu stellen statt sich
öffentlich mit dem gesundheitsminister
pausenlos zu streiten hätten sie besser
das von uns geforderte ins register auf
den weg gebracht das würde uns nämlich
heute in dieser zeit und in zukunft
ermöglichen die pandemie besser zu
managen das würde uns ermöglichen unsere
bürger besser zu schützen und das würde
es auch ermöglichen die grundrechte
besser zu schützen
es ist jetzt knapp ein jahr her
ein viertel der legislaturperiode ist
vorbei ich sage ihnen wenn sie wirklich
etwas für den rechtsstaat in unserem
land tun wollen dann fangen sie endlich
an richtig zu handeln und bessern sie
vor allen dingen noch beim haushalt nach
vielen dank er fordert hier andrea
lindholz für die cdu csu fraktion ist
sie stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende
und einen nachklapp zu den chor ohne
regeln gab es auch noch nie hat der
bundestag ja gerade heute beschlossen
für herbst und winter
und marco buschmann hatte die ja mit
seinem kabinettskollegen karl lauterbach
zusammen verhandelt
kollegen verehrte zuhörerinnen und
zuhörer diese haushaltsberatungen stehen
mehr denn je unter dem zeichen des
sparens der einhaltung der
schuldenbremse und dem ringen um die
maßnahmen und projekte die jetzt gerade
in einer zeit mit diversen haus für
herausforderungen parallel corona
ukraine krieg lieferengpässen inflation
steigende energie- und
lebenshaltungskosten von herausragender
bedeutung sind für die menschen in
unserem land theodor fontane wird das
zitat zugeschrieben eine richtige
sparsamkeit vergisst nie das nicht immer
gespart werden kann wer immer sparen
will der ist halloren auch moralisch
für uns sozialdemokraten gilt die
erkenntnis das investieren in der krise
und vor hohen folgekosten bewahrt die
dadurch entstünden wenn wir jetzt in der
krise nämlich nichts täten nur um keine
neuen schulden zu machen ja wir sind
bereit zu sparen aber bitte nicht kaputt
sparen liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
deshalb müssen wir alle möglichkeiten in
diesem haushalt ausschöpfen um das geld
was zur verfügung steht dort
zielgerichtet einzusetzen wo es jetzt am
dringendsten gebraucht wird für den
einzelplan 07 justiz haben wir am montag
bereits unser berichterstatter
bricht durchgeführt danke an den
hauptberichterstatter und das
ministerium für die organisation die
durchführung und insbesondere für die
beantwortung unserer fragen und die
erläuterung zu dem haushaltstitel im
justiz haushalt frau lindhorst sie haben
es gerade gesagt sind 953 millionen chf
4 954 quetsch betrachter zwischen euro
eingestellt insgesamt verzeichnet dieser
einzelplan einen geringen aufwuchs der
zum einen mit höheren ausgaben im
personalbereich zusammenhängt
insbesondere durch höhere zuweisungen an
den versorgungsfonds aber auch für
aufträge und dienstleistungen im bereich
informationstechnik von 70.000 euro im
jahr 2022
auf immerhin vier millionen 995 1000
euro im jahr 2023 für den aufbau von
daten laboren und dieser schwerpunkt des
justizministers auf digitalisierung
zeigt sich auch beim maßnahmen im
bereich des ministeriums selbst in dem
mittel in höhe von 3 millionen
eingeplant sind wichtig um den
bürgerinnen und bürgern den zugang zum
recht zu erleichtern und barrieren
abzubauen
bedauerlicherweise das ist unser
wermutstropfen kommen aber die belange
im kampf gegen extremismus hass und
hetze im netz gewalt gegenüber
minderheiten wie zuletzt in münster im
rahmen des csd und die beratung von
ehrenamtlichen kommunalpolitikerinnen
und kommunalpolitiker
bei digitalen angriffen noch zu kurz
sehr effektive projektförderungen laufen
aus zum beispiel für haye tate ohne dass
es eine folge lösung für betroffene gibt
sicherlich wäre es auch unsere
auffassung nach ein gutes zeichen
gewesen im hinblick auf die
gedenkveranstaltung mit dem israelischen
staatspräsidenten herzog am dienstag
dieser woche und der
ausstellungseröffnung im paul-löbe-haus
auch in diesem haushalt das
wohnungsbauprojekt für holocaust
überlebende in israel wieder mit einem
betrag von 200.000 euro zu unterstützen
wie wir es im parlament das verfahren
auch für den haushalt 2022 erneut
ausverhandelt haben
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ein thema
hat mich im einzelplan 07 besonders um
betrieben seit der gründung der stiftung
forum recht durch den deutschen
bundestag im jahr 2019 beschäftigt uns
das thema eigentlich in jeder
haushaltsdebatte die stiftung ist im
aufwachsen und ich kann von mir
behaupten dass ich diese gründung auch
persönlich
vorangetrieben habe und versucht habe
die beteiligten akteure endlich einmal
zusammenzuführen und dass dieses kind
des parlaments gut gedeiht ist mir
weiterhin ein großes anliegen diese
woche waren auch die beiden direktoren
der stiftung vor ort in berlin zum
gespräch bei mir und sicherlich auch bei
einigen von ihnen um für die aufstockung
der mittel für die stiftung zu bitten
warum er wenig dass liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen weil ich mitglied im
kuratorium bin und weil ich als
haushälterin für das bmj bei dem die
stiftung angesiedelt ist mehrfach beim
kuratorium auf die angespannte
haushaltslage des bundeshaushalts
hingewiesen und versucht habe die
erwartungen zu dämpfen
die zuweisung an die stiftungen würden
mittelfristig auf einen mittleren
zweistelligen millionenbetrag anwachsen
die stiftung erhält in diesem haushalt
denselben betrag wie in 2022 nämlich 35
millionen euro mithin aber 1,7 millionen
euro weniger als sie selbst in ihrer
haushaltsplanung veranschlagt und im
kuratorium beschlossen hat auch der
beschluss des kuratoriums
dem ich als haushälterin nicht zustimmen
konnte ich zitiere einmal das kuratorium
fordert den haushaltsgesetzgeber auf den
erfüllung aufwand der stiftung forum
recht in einem dem aufwuchs
auskömmlichen maße fortzuschreiben kann
aber nicht dazu führen dass dann diese
mittel auch zwangsläufig im
bundeshaushalt eingestellt werden und
der stiftung geht es in diesem jahr
leider wie vielen anderen projekten und
vorhaben in allen anderen einzugehen sie
sind betroffen von den sparmaßnahmen die
wir einhalten müssen umso mehr um in
sozialen bereichen dringend benötigtes
geld in die hand nehmen zu können alle
reden über entlastungspaket kritik wird
geäußert dass haben heute ja auch wieder
gehört es sei zu wenig es treffe zum
teil die falschen adressaten es sei
nicht bedarfsgerecht ich finde die
bisherigen entlastungspaket sehr gut und
umsichtig wenn jetzt auch die länder
ihren beitrag leisten kommen wir noch
mal einen guten schritt voran zum
beispiel mit einem folge angebot für das
man euro ticket
finanziell werden wir im haushalt des
bmj für entlastungspaket keine hilfen
leisten können aber
erstens sie haben es auch schon gesagt
herr dr buschmann bauen und planen
dauert zu lange dadurch werden die
kosten kaum noch kalkulierbar und hier
kann das ministerium einen wichtigen
beitrag leisten und gesetze zur planungs
und genehmigungsbescheide auf den weg
bringen und eventuell mit dem
bauministerium zusammen auch das
baugesetzbuch novellieren vorsorge im
justizbereich wurde bereits getroffen
und ein neuer senat beim
bundesverwaltungsgericht geschaffen um
dann auch bei zusätzlichen
klageverfahren diese schnell abarbeiten
zu können und dann nicht auch der
gerichts ebene die planungs
beschleunigung wieder zu profitieren
minister dr buschmann und das
ministerium kann auch sehr viel mehr zur
entlastung der bürgerinnen und bürger
beitragen nicht mit geld aber mit der
umsetzung der gesetzesvorhaben aus dem
koalitionsvertrag zum schutz von
mieterinnen und mietern und mieterschutz
regelungen verlängern die
kappungsgrenzen absenken die mietpreis
grenze verlängern qualifizierte
mietspiegel rechtssicher ausgestalten
und transparenz bei den nebenkosten
abrechnungen schaffen herr minister ich
hoffe all das es wird verlierer vorhaben
planung für das zweite halbjahr auch
noch umfasste auch wenn es dort nur mit
dem stichwort mietrecht ohne nähere
ausführungen in ihren plan aufgenommen
wurde das wäre eine echte entlastung der
bürgerinnen und bürger ohne dass sie in
ihrem haushalt auch nur einen euro dafür
investieren müssten
zum schluss möchte ich gerne mal auf den
vorwurf eingehen im ministerium oder
seitens des ministers würde kein geld
vorgesehen für den pakt für den
rechtsstaat oder für den digital pack
ich habe es eben auch schon dazwischen
gerufen wer das genau verfolgt hat und
jetzt mit haushaltsrecht auskennt der
weiß dass für den pakt für den
rechtsstaat niemals geld indem justiz
haushalt gestanden hat es wird über die
umsatzsteuer punkte geregelt das kann
auch nicht im
[Applaus]
bundesjustizministerin namen der
umsatzsteuer zwischen bund und ländern
aufgeteilt werden dann können auch die
länder verdammt noch mal über pflicht
nachkommen sich an den finanziellen
kosten für ausgaben für länderaufgaben
zumindest beteiligen denn justiz ist
nunmal länder aufgabe und ich finde
schon großartig wenn wir als bund die
hand ausstrecken und mit den ländern
gemeinsam einen pakt für den rechtsstaat
auf gestalten und genau das wird auch im
digital pack zu sein wir dürfen es aus
verfassungsrechtlichen gründen gar nicht
in den justiz haushalt schreiben und das
sollten die und genau darum geht es wenn
sie uns vorwerfen ist steht nicht drin
es kann eben auch nicht drin stehen
lesen sie das
[Applaus]
so weit ist der den ich ja für die spd
sie ist er mitglied des
haushaltsausschusses so auch der nächste
redner michael eller für die fdp
fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kollegen liebe zuschauer im saal
und bei youtube wenn es um die lage der
justiz und des rechts in deutschland
geht dann weiß man gar nicht wo man
anfangen und wo man aufhören so denn
vieles davon ist einfach nur noch wir
befinden uns in einer rechts
positivistischen spirale in dem die
produkte der rechtssetzung dieses
parlaments zu nehmen willkürlich werden
und völlig entrückt sind von jeder form
von rationalität zahlen daten und fakten
spielen scheinbar keine rolle mehr
gerade vorhin haben wir hier über das
infektionsschutzgesetz abgestimmt ein
gesetz das es schlicht und einfach nicht
braucht ein gesetz das die
ampelkoalition in einer phase
verabschiedet hat in der korona längst
zu ende nie geworden ist während der
regierung fast wahnhaft immer noch
versucht eine pandemie herbeizureden
eine so genannte pandemie die wenn man
der logik der regierung folgt ihre opfer
nicht in deutschen regierungsflieger
gefällt wohl aber in normalen verkehrs
fliegern im deutschen luftraum wissen
wie man dort bisher maske tragen muss im
regierungsflieger eben nicht von der spd
und den grünen ist man ja einiges an
rationalität gewohnt doch von einer
partei wie die fdp die sich noch immer
als rechtsstaatspartei bezeichnet hätte
man mehr erwartet
[Applaus]
doch dieses label hat sich als
etikettenschwindel entpuppt denn der fdp
justizminister ist nicht in der lage
oder nicht willens diesen begriff auch
tatsächlich mit leben zu füllen und das
ist überhaupt und im allgemeinen die
ganze gruppe bei der sache nachdem man
in zeiten der aufklärung
herausgearbeitet hat das exekutive
judikative und legislative niemals in
einer hand vereint sein sollen haben wir
in deutschland ein absolut vorbildliches
system der gewaltenteilung der arbeitet
erkämpft und eingerichtet schön dass
wieder lachen ergänzt wird dieses system
von der sogenannten vierten gewaltfreie
medien die der theorie nach alle anderen
drei gewalten kontrollieren sollen
dieses system steht und es sieht gut aus
und doch drängt sich bei immer mehr
menschen der gedanke auf dass es
vielleicht alten nur noch eine leere
hülle ist dass die gewaltenteilung zwar
auf dem papier existiert aber eben nicht
mehr gelebt wird beispielsweise dann
wenn die vertreter der vierten gewalt
mit im regierungsflieger sitzen selbst
gegen recht und gesetz verstoßen indem
sie dort eben keine maske tragen und
diese an eine zwischenfrage jahren als
cola und das unglück gerne als
kurzintervention gleich soll diesen
rechtsverstoß dann auch hin trotzigen
leitartikeln verteidigen statt sich in
demut zu üben vom bundesjustizminister
übrigens kein wort zu diesem 2 klasse
recht klar nach der öffentlichen
empörung wenn man jetzt die masken
pflicht in flugzeug abschaffen obwohl
auch deshalb weil das staatliche
gewaltmonopol gedroht das gesicht zu
verlieren die masken pflicht im
deutschen luftraum ist ein
internationaler exot und längst nicht
mehr durchsetzbar aber der minister hält
fest an der masken pflicht im zug an der
möglichkeit zur demonstrationsverboten
ausgangssperren schulschließungen und
neuen lockdown und das obwohl herr dr
buschmann uns allen doch das absolute
ende dieser maßnahmen versprochen hat
maßnahmen schon im letzten und auch im
vorletzten jahr von der wissenschaft als
in großen teilen unsinnig bewertet wurde
ich weiß politiker setzen häufig darauf
dass die menschen schnell vergessen aber
wir alle haben doch die bilder im kopf
polizisten die im winter schlittenfahren
den kindern hinterher jagen das hat sich
in das kollektive gedächtnis dieser
nation für immer eingebrannt ebenso wie
die oft rabiate auflösung von
demonstrationen gegen korona politik
weil dort im freien keine maske getragen
wurde während sich das gewaltmonopol
daran bei demonstrationen unter dem
banner der friday futures schulschwänzer
nicht störte resultat solcher exekutiv
leistungen und rechtssetzung akten mit
dem infektionsschutzgesetz ist dass
nicht nur das vertrauen in den
rechtsstaat sinkt sondern das in die
leistungsfähigkeit des staates selbst
laut einer aktuellen umfrage des forsa-
von forsa im auftrag der db sind nur
noch 29 prozent der bundesbürger aktuell
der meinung dass der staat in der lage
ist seine aufgaben zu erfüllen und das
sollte uns alle aufrütteln und ganz
besonders auch den justizminister denn
das bundesjustizministerium wirkt war
aufgabenbeschreibung bei allen gesetzen
und verordnungen entwurf für andere
bundesministerien mit ich komme mir
ziemlich tourismus und in diesem
zusammenhang sollte sich auch ein
justizminister dafür stark machen dass
das wort evidenz nicht zum fremdwort in
unserer rechtssetzung wird herzlichen
dank
michael aston villa war das und ob nun
bundestagsvize präsidentin eine
kurzintervention zulässt das liegt in
ihrem ermessen
nein also geht es weiter mit der
rednerliste bühne spricht
sie haben jetzt viel geredet nix zum
haushalt gesagt sie haben offensichtlich
nur zu youtube tatsächlich geredet mein
kollege till steffen hat gesagt er
glaubt nicht dass das viral geht ich
kann mich da nur anschließen sehr
geehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen sie wissen der
einzelplan 7 der etat des bmj ist ein
personal geprägter verwaltungshaushalt
die ausgaben sind stabil unter einer
milliarde das notwendige im
zuständigkeitsbereich des bmj wird
finanziert und die einnahmen decken die
ausgaben zu zwei dritteln auf stabilem
niveau von den haushältern ist das
tatsächlich sehr sehr erfreulich und
auch bei genauerer betrachtung kann
festgehalten werden dass der vorliegende
entwurf grundsolider ist so hat es ja
auch der bundesrechnungshof bestätigt
und auch wenn das alles recht
unspektakulär klingt die
herausforderungen für unseren
rechtsstaat die sind natürlich riesig in
einer globalisierten welt wird auch die
frage von recht und gerechtigkeit
komplexer die justiz behörden und
gerichte sind den anforderungen unserer
krisenhaften zeit ausgesetzt und auch
sie müssen mit der zeit gehen wenn die
korona pandemie uns eines gezeigt hat
dann ist es doch dass wir in der
digitalisierung massiv hinterher hängen
noch immer werden schriftsätze zuhauf
online verschickt nur und dann bei
gericht wieder ausgedruckt und wieder
einige scans zu werden es ist also kein
wunder dass deutschland im eu justiz
barometer
2021 bei der digitalisierung nur
mittelfeld gelangt ist das bedeutet für
uns der digital pakt für den rechtsstaat
den wir im koalitionsvertrag
verankert haben muss hier liefern wir
stehen gemeinsam mit den ländern in der
verantwortung für eine justiz auf der
höhe der zeit
wichtig wichtig ist also dass wir das
ding hier genau aufs gleis setzen der
minister hat seine bereitschaft auch in
finanzierungsfragen hier bekundet wir
nehmen sie beim wort lieber minister
marco buschmann mit blick auf die
stellenpläne möchte ich zwei sehr
positive entwicklungen herausstellen sie
alle wissen der völkerrechtswidrige
russische angriffskrieg gegen die
ukraine dauert an monate der brutalität
monate der zerstörung und der massaker
an der zivilbevölkerung deswegen ist es
essentiell dass der generalbundesanwalt
gut ausgestattet ist gerade im bereich
der internationalen kooperation wir
wollen und wir müssen unseren beitrag
leisten damit die gräueltaten aufgeklärt
werden dafür haben wir im 22er haushalt
den generalbundesanwalt besser
ausgestattet und das setzen den uns fort
wir sorgen also dafür dass täter zur
rechenschaft gezogen werden können es
darf und es wird keine blaupause für
kriegsverbrechen geben nicht im inland
nicht im ausland genau das stellen wir
mit diesem haushalt sichern
und auch beim
bundesverwaltungsgericht sind zwölf neue
stellen für einen klimaschutz sind
vorgesehen da geht es darum
planungsverfahren zu beschleunigen den
ausbau der erneuerbaren voranzutreiben
dass das eine querschnittsaufgabe
herausragender bedeutung ist das zeigt
sich daran dass klimaschutz jetzt sogar
im einzelplan 7 etatisiert ist und das
ist genau richtig so liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
die wichtigste und nobelste aufgabe des
justizministeriums ist die stärkung
unseres rechtsstaates wo immer der
rechtsstaat schwächelt sind demokratie
feinde nicht fern um ihre toxischen
thesen zu verbreiten
sie sitzen auch hier im bundestag die
freunde der desinformation und der
aufwiegelei die freunde putins da ganz
als koalition sehen wir im bereich der
hasskriminalität
analog wie digital einen dringenden
handlungsbedarf im bundesministerium für
justiz haben wir dafür stellen
geschaffen die sich der bekämpfung und
verfolgung von hass und hetze widmen als
mitglied einer bürgerrechtspartei ist
für mich dabei aber eine sache wirklich
zentralen gegen rechtsverstöße im
internet muss konsequent vorgegangen
werden aber gleichzeitig müssen
freiheits und bürgerrechte auch in der
digitalen welt gewahrt werden hier die
richtige balance zu finden muss für und
demokratinnen essentiell sein ob
online-durchsuchungen schwellentäter
oder anlasslose vorratsdatenspeicherung
mehr überwachung bringt nicht
automatisch mehr sicherheit so viel ist
klar liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
umso wichtiger umso wichtiger ist eine
zielgerichtete evaluation dieser
maßnahmen genau das bringt die
ampelkoalition mit der überwachungs
gesamtrechnung auf den weg die mittel
dafür stehen bereit und das sind
letztendlich mittel für freiheits und
bürgerrechte und eine evidenzbasierte
sicherheitspolitik auch das steckt im
einzelplan 7 ich bin überzeugt das ist
der richtige weg und das gleiche gilt
auch für diesen haushalt herzlichen dank
ohnehin war das für bündnis 90 die
grünen auch erst mitglied im
haushaltsausschuss
die nächste rednerin
clara jünger ist sprecherin für
rechtspolitik der linksfraktion
sehr geehrte präsidentin sehr geehrter
herr minister liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen der demokratischen fraktionen
das neuen euro ticket ist jetzt seit
acht tagen geschichte es ist wirklich
bedauerlich dass sie dieses erfolgreiche
projekt so schnell wieder begraben haben
stattdessen soll es jetzt einen 49 oder
69 euro ticket geben das als nachfolger
tickets zu verkaufen verkennt die
prekäre situation in der sich viele
menschen in diesem land befinden
millionen menschen werden ab jetzt
wieder vom recht auf mobilität
ausgeschlossen sein wir müssen aber
nicht über die frage nur über die fragen
der mobilität sprechen sondern auch über
die bestrafung von armut in diesem
kontext ich habe bei der deutschen bahn
nachgefragt wie viele menschen bei
kontrollen ohne ticket angetroffen
wurden das ergebnis ist eindeutig bevor
es das neun euro ticket gab sind über
214.000 personen ohne ticket angetroffen
worden im gleichen zeitraum dieses
jahres waren es nur gut 120 1000 die
zahl der menschen die ohne ticket
gefahren sind hat sich in der zeit ist
euro tickets also fast halbiert und es
ist falsch was sie sagen von der cdu das
lag nicht daran dass in diesem jahr
weniger und vor allem gegeben hat laut
informationen des deutschen verbandes
der verkehrsbetriebe wurden die
kontrollen nämlich nicht
heruntergefahren während des neuen euro
ticken
und was passierte für sie können selber
nachfragen und was passiert mit menschen
die sich kein ticket leisten können und
dann kontrolliert werden sie müssen
nicht nur ein erhöhtes
beförderungsentgelt an das
verkehrsunternehmen zahlen sondern in
droht auch noch dazu eine haft- oder
geldstrafe
das paradoxe ist werde ich schon nicht
genug geld für ein ticket hat erst recht
nicht genug geld um das forum die um die
erhöhte entgeltzahlungen für das
unternehmen zu bezahlen
und er hat und das was ist die
konsequenz für diese menschen für diese
menschen hat das fahren ohne fahrschein
die konsequenz die ersatzfreiheitsstrafe
also der ersatz für das zahlen der
geldstrafe gehen menschen ins gefängnis
damit bestraft man arme doppelt
viele gar nicht gewusst was das konkret
für die betroffenen bedeutet ihnen droht
der verlust der wohnung und des
arbeitsplatzes das haben sie herr
buschmann in ihrem referenten den 15
sanktions rechts recht übrigens sogar
selbst erkannt und ich zitiere da
schreiben sie in dem entwurf in
bestimmten konstellationen kann der
vollzug der ersatzfreiheitsstrafe sogar
zu einer weit und sozialisierung führen
etwa durch den verlust der wohnung oder
des arbeitsplatzes
das bedeutet für viele menschen eine
zusätzliche bestrafung stigmatisierung
und soziale isolierung wenn sie das
schon in ihrem eigenen referentenentwurf
erkannt haben wie so handeln sie dann
nicht danach weist die gesagt haben eine
bloße halbierung der tat keineswegs für
die menschen und hilft auch nicht das
grundproblem der bestrafung der arm und
abzuschaffen oder finden sie das gerecht
dass menschen wegen fahrens ohne
fahrschein ins gefängnis kommen meistens
auch noch sogar ohne jemals vor einem
richter gestanden zu haben ich nicht und
ich möchte es auch an einem beispiel
deutlich punkten er wurde wegen einer
sogenannten beförderungserschleichung zu
einer zweieinhalbjährigen haftstrafe
verurteilt weil er die geldstrafe von
8000 euro nicht aufbringen konnte nur zu
verdeutlichen hat nicht wie andere
delikte sich strafbar gemacht seine
zweieinhalb jahre knast beruhe lediglich
auf verurteilung wegen wiederholten
fahrens und fahrschein das ist doch
absurd
wir heißen
inhaftiert das wissen sie auch herr
buschmann in deutschen gefängnissen
sitzen eine ersatzfreiheitsstrafe
das betrifft jährlich 50.000 menschen
das ist doch absurd das ist nicht nur
eine katastrophe für die betroffenen
sondern verursacht auch extrem hoher
kosten für den staat deutschlandweit
werden pro tag
450.000 euro ausgegeben um menschen zu
inhaftieren die eine geldstrafe zahlen
konnten häufig wegen fahren ohne
fahrschein das sind 164 millionen euro
im jahr und die kosten der justiziellen
verfolgung sind da noch nicht mal
inbegriffen dieses geld dann doch an
anderer stelle so viel sinnvoller
eingesetzt werden
zur arbeit fahren freundinnen und
verwandten besuchen oder einfach nur in
die natur fahren ist bisher häufig ein
privileg von reichen menschen das darf
aber nicht so bleiben mobilität darf
kein luxus sein sondern es muss jede
mode ermöglicht wird deswegen setzen wir
uns auch als linke dafür ein dass ein
kostenloser und
vor dem hintergrund der tatsache dass
durch krise und inflation noch mehr
menschen sich die mobilität nicht mehr
leisten können sollten sie das fahren
ohne fahrschein
entkriminalisiert und schaffen sie die
ersatzfreiheitsstrafe komplett ab machen
sie hier doch keine halben sachen vielen
dank
klara dünner war das für die linke und
ja das schwarzfahren also ohne ticket
öffentlichen verkehr zu fahren nicht
mehr als straftat sondern als
ordnungswidrigkeit gelten sollte ist
eine debatte dazu haben wir eben unter
anderem auch schon agenturmeldungen von
1995 gefunden sie hält also schon länger
an thorsten gibt spricht jetzt für die
fdp-fraktion
präsidentin der bundesminister dr usman
verehrte kolleginnen und kollegen liebe
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer gerne
zurück zur einzelplan beratung 07 sehr
geehrte frau kollegin
lindholms klar und deutlich auch hier
noch mal zu sagen mit der fdp wird es
keine anlasslose vorratsdatenspeicherung
geben ausrufezeichen punkt und sie auf
die bgh-entscheidung hinweisen dann
lesen sie bitte einfach nochmal
insgesamt durch und sehen sich die vier
optionen an wir bewegen uns mit unseren
vorschlägen im rahmen der rechtsprechung
und das noch einmal ganz deutlich zu
sagen die
ampelkoalition die überlegenen kollegen
hat sich ein ambitioniertes rechts
politisches reformprogramm vorgenommen
hier zeigt sich insbesondere der
aufbruch dieser fortschritts koalition
für dieses land und es ist gut und
richtig so dass wir dieses signal setzen
wir reden heute über den
haushaltsmäßigen rahmen für die
umfangreichen rechtspolitische vorhaben
der koalition über 950 millionen euro er
fährt der haushalt einen leichten
aufwuchs dass vor allem mit der
verbesserten stellenbesetzung boote zu
gut dass es gelingt qualifiziertes
personal für diese so wichtige haus zu
gewinnen und liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen von der union ich hätte das
wahnsinnig gerne heute auch mit ihrer
haushalts berichterstatterin frau
hoppermann diskutiert was sie hier
vielleicht noch verändern und besser
machen
inhaltlich aber eines klar zu sagen
hätte ich heute hätte ich heute am
liebsten über den pakt für den
rechtsstaat über den digital pakt für
justiz über erste vorhaben intensiv
diskutiert nämlich immer die frage was
können wir als bund dazu beitragen dass
wir gemeinsam bund und länder justiz
weiter nach vorne bringen vor allem im
digitalen umfeld aber wie wir sehen die
bundesratsbank ist nicht besetzt eine
diskussion mit den bundesländern ist
heute nicht möglich eines möchte ich an
dieser stelle auch noch mal festhalten
die haben das vereinbart und schlagen
das vor im koalitionsvertrag und wir
stehen dazu wir stehen dazu als bunt wir
reichen die hand der bundesminister hat
es vorhin bereits angesprochen aber um
eines noch einmal ganz deutlich und
klipp und klar von dieser stelle aus zu
sagen es geht mitnichten darum und
mitnichten ist dass unser vorhaben sei
auch verfassungsrechtlich problematisch
dass wir aus dem bundeshaushalt nicht
rational stellen in den bundesländern
dauern das finanzieren und genau dieser
vorschlag ist vor einigen tagen gekommen
ganz klares nein das wird es nie und
nimmer geben das darf es nicht geben uns
geht es um gemeinsame projekt und die
sind dringend nötig im bereich der
justiz viele kolleginnen kollegen
sagt justiz laut als eine idee ich sage
gemeinsames vernetzung darüber müssen
wir reden dazu reichen wir die hand und
da freuen wir uns auf die diskussion ist
die vorschläge der bundesländer und wir
lassen uns nicht vorwerfen und der
bundesregierung im deutschen bundestag
dass wir nicht bereit sind das zu
diskutieren wenn konkrete und richtig
gute vorschläge kommen die aktuellen
herausforderungen nächster punkt im
energiesektor und ich sage ganz bewusst
nicht merkte damit machten hat es
reichlich wenig zu tun wie diese
struktur im augenblick aussieht machen
deutlich die vorausschauend wie als
ampelkoalition waren als sie von anfang
an das thema planungs beschleunigung
sowohl im verwaltungs mäßigen als auch
ein gerichtsverfahren angesprochen und
angeregt werden das bmj auch das hat
herr bundesminister buschmann schon
gesagt ist vorangegangen hat einen
ersten sehr guten vorschlag vorgelegt um
im bereich der
verwaltungsgerichtsordnung nach vorne
nach vorne zu kommen mit der schaffung
eben das schon mehrfach genannten
zusätzlichen senates beim
bundesverwaltungsgerichts das ist die
richtige antwort des rechtsstaates zur
rechten zeit handeln ist das gebot der
stunde denn nur wenn planungs
beschleunigungen der jal und chrysler
wird dann gelingen die dringend
notwendigen zukunftsinvestitionen in die
bereiche verkehr energieversorgung die
wir dringend brauchen in diesem land für
ihre kollegin kolleg
abschließender aspekt eine fundamentale
aufgabe auch der rechtspolitik ist und
bleibt die förderung von innovationen in
diesem land mit dem deutschen patent und
markenamt haben wir im geschäftsbereich
des
bundesjustizministerium einer der
weltweit anerkanntesten behörden für die
sicherung von geistigen eigentum es ist
daher ein gutes zeichen für die
sicherung von innovationen in diesem
land das auch des dpa bei
stellenbesetzungen gut vorangekommen ist
und es erweist sich als sehr kluge
entscheidung den standort jena weiter zu
starten noch dort die gewinnung von
fachkräften zu erleichtern
das ist ein fundamentaler beitrag ohne
die weltweit denen die weltweit
anerkannte hohe qualität die
entscheidung des dpm a und unserer
entsprechenden gerichte aufrechterhalten
werden kann noch und den bereichen die
die verfahren weiter vorantreiben können
das ist auch und das will ich bewusst
zum schluss betonen ein ganz
fundamentaler beitrag im weltweiten
systemwettbewerb auch auf die frage des
schutzes der gestaltung und der
weiterentwicklung von innovationen und
geistigen eigentums und augenbereich
spielen dort warten also zahlreiche
herausforderung auf uns in die beratung
ich freue mich braucht vielen dank
soweit der stellvertretende vorsitzende
des rechtsausschusses
hier zum einzelplan
71 und carsten müller ist der nächste
redner auch erst mitglied im
rechtsausschuss
dass wir eben jetzt die eigenwahrnehmung
der justizpolitik ampelkoalition die
menschen im lande und wir als opposition
nehmen das übrigens ganz anders wahr
herr kollege dr und wie sozusagen
rechtspolitik im gestreckten galopp
ihrer bundesregierung aussieht das haben
wir heute beim infektionsschutzgesetz
gesehen da gingen einige wochen und
monate wechselseitiger beleidigung und
herabsetzung von mitgliedern der
bundesregierung der bundesregierung
voran und am ende des tages mündete
alles in einem chaos nationaler
tragweite
das ist nämlich übrigens die wahrnehmung
in der öffentlichkeit und meine damen
und herren was werden wir bekommen und
wir bekommen eine ampel regulatorischen
flickenteppich in der krone frage aber
dieses chaos nationaler tragweite
betrifft bei weitem eben nicht nur
dieses feld der korona politik ich
greife mal das thema
unterstützung der ukraine auf thema
waffenlieferungen wir erinnern uns noch
an die ein oder andere einlassung der
kabinettskollegin des kollegen buschmann
der kabinettskollegin lamprecht dazu ist
vielmehr nicht zu sagen sie haben eben
selber sich aus rimmels der
energiepolitik bewegt also die
untaugliche gas umlage an der im übrigen
der kollege dr buschmann an der
verordnung beteiligt war die ist
mittlerweile legendär
sie finden sie finden in der bevölkerung
niemanden mehr der sie dafür lobt und
verteidigt schon mal gerade gar nicht
und meine damen und herren wir gucken
uns mal das herz der deutschen
wirtschaft an den mittelstand der zdh
meldet land unter die bäckereien sind
verzweifelt
ich will jetzt gar nicht vor ihm ging es
ja um die frage was geht viral und was
geht nicht wir alle in dieser woche sehr
geehrter herr kollege bei dem auftrag
des rechts von saerbeck ist einfach kein
platz mehr für andere beiträge die viral
gehen können das muss man mal zugestehen
aber meine damen und herren das thema
insolvenz will ist ein riesiges und es
geht vor allen dingen darum dass wir den
mittelstand und zwar den
gesellschaftlichen und den
wirtschaftlichen mittelstand in diesem
lande unterstützen das fordert die union
und meine damen und herren was macht die
bundesregierung
das justizministerium überlegt sich das
insolvenzrecht möglicherweise ein
bisschen zu ändern da wird's noch im
übrigen eine reihe von erklärungs und
erläuterung gesprächen mit dem
bundeswirtschaftsminister geben müssen
das haben wir alle erfahren in wahrheit
aber braucht der mittelstand konkrete
hilfe und wenn diese
unendlich peinlicher auftritt des
bundeswirtschaftsministers habeck die
vorgestern abend zu etwas gut war dann
doch dazu dass er heute bei drehen
musste und er in aussicht gestellt hat
dass auch kleine und mittlere
unternehmen in das energiekosten
dämpfungs programm aufgenommen werden
könnten passiert es im übrigen noch
nichts er ist eine forderung der union
und die öffentlichkeit fordert dass und
sieben müssen diesen nachgehen und das
finden wir richtig so interessant ist im
übrigen dass ausgerechnet unter einer
von der fdp mitgetragen
bundesregierung der deutsche mittelstand
so abgewickelt wird meine damen und
herren die soll das justizministerium
darum justizministerium darüber besorgt
seinen rechtswidrigen recht systematik
in gesetze und verordnungen zu
gewährleisten das passiert nicht ich
will ihnen mal einige beispiele nennen
sie haben auf die länder bank abgehoben
das verhältnis zwischen den
landesjustizminister übrigens egal
welcher couleur sie können ja mal die
grüne kollegin aus hamburg fragen und
dem bundesjustizminister ist
ich will sagen ich will nicht sagen
zerrüttet aber ist es im moment gar
nicht mehr gegeben weil es einfach von
ignoranz geprägt dass der
bundesjustizminister bei der umicore
machten eher gelangweilten gelangweilten
zu beschreiten ein und dafür gibt es
eine reihe von wichtigen themenpark für
den rechtsstaat steht in ihrem
koalitionsvertrag im seit neun monaten
passiert nicht und wir merken doch wie
sie sich aus schülern wie ansuchen meine
damen und herren das nächste beispiel
wir nehmen das beispiel
hochsicherheitsgebäude am
oberlandesgericht in celle es stand im
haushalt eine verpflichtungsermächtigung
über 24 millionen euro es wurde
gefordert von bmj ein länder
staatsvertrag zwischen den ländern
niedersachsen thüringen und sachsen
anhalt denkbar unterschiedliche
farbzusammensetzung der regierung die
linde haben sich zusammengerauft es
klappt der vorhang ist bremst das
bundesjustizministerium kommt nicht in
die pötte und die länder stehen da und
sagen was sollen wir denn bitte noch tun
meine damen und herren haben muss etwas
passieren und ich will ein weiteres
beispiel geliefert wir haben einiges
über die ukraine und über freiheit wird
von ihnen sehr geehrter herr
justizminister ich bin schockiert dass
sie ihr haus die mittel für das institut
für rost recht in den kommenden jahren
sukzessive bis auf null zurückfahren
wollen wir haben dieser tage die
justizminister aus georgien und der
ukraine da gab die haben sich
unterstützung durch uns sie und ihre
position machen genau das gegenteil
worin mündete ich will immer ich habe
auch ein anderer stelle heute den
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister gehört er
hat max frisch zitiert richtig gutes
zitat krise ist ein produktiver zustand
man muss ihr nur den beigeschmack der
katastrophe nehmen meine damen und
herren mit dieser bundesregierung haben
sie die garantie dass aus jeder krise
eine katastrophe wird und die menschen
im land merken dass sie können das nicht
mehr wegdiskutieren
und für die spd fraktion hat das foto
nja ich wieder
turniere
rechtspolitische sprecherin der spd
fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrter herr bundesjustizminister
buschmann werte kolleginnen und kollegen
der demokratischen fraktion wir
diskutieren heute über den
haushaltsentwurf des bundesministeriums
der justiz und damit über einen bereich
der wie kein anderer für das fundament
unseres rechtsstaates steht oft wirkt er
wie ein brennglas auf die sozialen
herausforderungen
für unsere gesellschaft und unseren
gesellschaftlichen
zusammenhalt technisch gesprochen ist
der einzelplan 07 einen haushalt der
stark durch personalausgaben geprägt ist
wir haben es in der debatte schon
vielfach gehört tatsächlich stehen aber
diese ausgaben für personen die unseren
rechtsstaat nach außen repräsentieren
ihm leibhaftig machen erwähnt wurde
dabei der neue senat des
bundesverwaltungsgerichts
der sehr sehr wichtig ist und auch zeigt
dass die regierung ist nicht nur ernst
meint mit guten ideen mit der frage der
planungs beschleunigung mit der
reformierung der
verwaltungsgerichtsordnung sondern auch
weiß was es hier für die umsetzung
braucht nämlich entsprechenden stellen
in der bundeswehr
neben dem personal sind wichtige
einzelne projekte in dem haushalt
enthalten auf einige haben meine
vorredner in gewiesen beispielsweise
möchte ich aber die weitere
unterstützung der magnus hirschfeld
stiftung nennen die auch für einen guten
effektiven rechtsstaat zusammen mit uns
kämpft im parlamentarischen verfahren
werden wir uns noch für weitere projekte
einsetzen die es auch zu fördern gilt in
diesem sinne
zu unserer demokratie gehört es dass
menschen auch recht bekommen dass die
justiz effektiv ist das haben wir uns
als ampel regierung vorgenommen dafür
ist dieser haushaltsentwurf ein sehr
sehr gutes beispiel da wir bereits auf
viele haushalterische details in der
debatte eingegangen sind ist es mir ein
anliegen noch ein augenmerk auf einen
bereich zulegen der eng mit der
ausstattung der justiz zu tun hat der
vom bundesminister und auch von
opposition teilweise genannt ist
wir haben es momentan mit steigenden
lebenshaltungskosten zu tun ausgelöst
durch den völkerrechtswidrigen
angriffskrieg in der ukraine durch den
russischen staat der auch uns eben vor
große herausforderungen stellt deswegen
haben wir die entlastungs pakete die
sehr sehr wichtig sind für den
zusammenhalt in unserem land denn wir
wissen dass soziale insbesondere
personen mit wenig geld am stärksten
treffen als ehemalige strafrichterin das
ist deshalb mir ein besonderes anliegen
auch auf personen hinzuweisen die eben
von armut betroffen sind oder von armut
gefährdet sind und sich in der besonders
wohlhabenden
situation eines strafverfahrens befinden
gerade in
finanziell schwierigen situationen hat
ein strafrichter eine geldstrafe für
straf und schuld angemessen gehalten ist
es aber dieser person trotzdem ohne
rücklagen und mit einem geringen
monatlichen einkommen sehr sehr schwer
geld am monatsende zu entbehren um eben
einen entsprechenden tagessatz zu zahlen
das risiko dass die strafe in einem
gefängnis verbüßt werden muss ist sehr
sehr hoch hier müssen wir anpacken hier
werden die anpacken her der
bundesjustizminister einen guten
referentenentwurf mit seinem ministerium
vorgelegt er jetzt ins parlamentarische
verfahren geht ich will trotzdem
deutlich machen dass der handlungsbedarf
hier auch im vergleich zu unseren
nachbarländern sehr sehr groß ist in
deutschland hat im vergleich in europa
sehr viele personen die einer
ersatzfreiheitsstrafe verbüßen es sind
aufs jahr gerechnet sogar mehr als die
hälfte der personen die sich in
justizvollzugsanstalten
befinden und eben in einer sozial
schwierigeren lage ein thema auf dass
wir hier auch als regierung eben
entsprechend durch eine überarbeitung
des strafrechtlichen sanktionen systems
eingehen müssen und eingehen wollen
das gebietet nicht nur die gerechtigkeit
sondern ist eben auch eine frage
haushalt irischer vernunft da ist hier
bei den ländern zu großen einsparungen
kommen wird in diesen politisch
herausfordernden zeiten müssen wir für
eine gut funktionierende justiz sorgen
für eine gut funktionierende
strafjustiz für eine umsetzung des
digital parks für eine ausgestaltung des
paktes für den rechtsstaat sehr geehrter
herr kollege müller wo es ja verhandlung
gibt zu der bundesjustizminister darauf
hingewiesen hat dass wir uns und sie
sagen ja sie sind eine
rechtsstaatspartei aber eben natürlich
auch in den grenzen des grundgesetzes in
den zuständigkeiten hier bewegen müssen
ist vollkommen klar deshalb kann der der
bund nur strukturell die länder
unterstützen aber dabei stehen wir auch
zu unserem wort im wissen dass es gerade
in der krise besonders wichtig ist dies
zu tun
wir wissen dass der rechtsstaat
effektiver werden muss dass die justiz
effektiv ausgestaltet werden muss der
haushaltsentwurf bietet dafür eine gute
grundlage eine gute
diskussionsgrundlage ich freue mich sehr
auf die anstehenden verhandlungen und
die haushaltsberatung vielen dank
sonja ich wähle war das und meine damen
und herren sie sehen wir schauen auch
nach schottland innen großbritannien
sind ärzte besorgt über den
gesundheitszustand der queen sie hält
sich auf schloss balmoral auf teile der
königsfamilie sind dort schon hin geeilt
wir beobachten die situation wissen
fraktionen hier im hause also der afd
lieber andere abgeordneten der anderen
fraktionen liebe zuhörer und zuschauer
vom busch manchen es gibt ein absolutes
ende der korona maßnahmen am 20 märz
2022 bis zur drohenden
demonstrationsverboten fb2 masken
pflicht in zügen und wo ständig ja auch
in flugzeugen war es nur ein paar nur
ein paar monaten ist gott sei dank die
masten pflicht in flugzeugen erspart
geblieben nachdem scholz seine maske
offenbar vergessen hatte und habe die
ganze geschichte nicht ganz ernst
genommen hat auf dem in den
regierungsflieger der bestückt war auch
mit vielen vertretern
der presse also nun endlich die masken
und pflichten zu kirchen flieger die das
virus scheint irgendwie verkehrsmittel
abhängig zu sein was macht das
justizministerium aus meinen aus einem
menschen in kürzester zeit mars war
hambrecht lamprecht die liste der
gescheiterten
justizminister ist lang und das
scheitern geht jetzt offenbar mit marco
buschmann weiter was macht das
justizministerium aus einem mutmaßlich
freiheitlichen geist wie marco buschmann
es 1 tor gab zu sein dass fdp steht für
freie für freiheit inzwischen eher für
feigheit für fiasko für flachdächer für
flexibel für freund lauterbachs das
waren das heute für kleinliche
lobhudeleien von porta bei ihm gegenüber
er muss man also ich wäre vor scham im
boden versunken lauter mal mich dermaßen
loben würde und arbeite daran dass dazu
nicht kommen wird
statt freiheit des geistes der freiheit
regiert im justizministerium nun links
grüner quatsch anders kann man das nicht
beziffern oder bezeichnen quer wohnte
trans geschlechtlichkeit beschäftigt sie
offenbar über die woche die elternrechte
und eltern stellung werden nach
beliebigkeit demnächst verteilt angriffe
auf das bürgerliche gesetzbuch massiven
grundrechtseingriff
drohen im herbst heute verabschiedet das
infektionsschutzgesetz es wurde schon
einige male erwähnt ein gesetz der
schande meine damen und herren ein
katalog der grausamkeiten den sie da
draußen den bürgern den menschen im
lande wieder zumuten stadt ende aller
maßnahmen vor einem halben jahr das
genau im gegenteil es gedankengut und
schaffen des justizminister ist das
ehemalige liberalen buschmann geworden
carlo collodi lässt grüßen carlo collodi
ist derjenige der pinocchio erfunden hat
ich weiß nicht wer von ihnen mal in die
post geschaut hat vor einiger zeit da
ist tatsächlich der kollege buschmann
analog zu carlo collodi abgebildet
worden das dachte ich mir das stelle ich
meine ich überreichen das leicht stellen
sich auf dem schreibtisch der busch
immer dass es sich wieder daran erinnern
was sie mal waren an der liebe ein
liberaler politiker wie einer freilich
ein paar tage hat ihre deutsche damen
und herren die ist die freiheitliche
demokratische partei in deutschland für
freiheit für rechtsstaat für demokratie
für gewaltenteilung dafür stehen und nur
hier wir sind keine pinocchio partei wie
sie alle anderen wir sind eine partei
ernst genommen werden muss und noch
viele viele jahre in demokratisch
schalten und walten wie vielen dank
stefan brandner von der fdp fraktion war
dass hierzu justizpolitik und zum
entwurf 2023 für das
justizministerium
253 4 2 millionen euro sind vorgesehen
[Applaus]
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
also ich weiß nicht wie es ihnen geht
aber bei der letzten rede und
tatsächlich auch bei den beiden reden
aus der unionsfraktion gab es bei der
letzten gar keine bei den anderen nur
minimale kritik am justiz aus als ich
darauf dass als allgemein breite
zufriedenheit mit dem haushaltsentwurf
im bereich der justiz hier werden und
darüber freue ich mich darüber freue ich
mich auf jeden fall
das ist sicherlich auf einer
realistischen angemessen einschätzung
liebe
liebe kollegin kaja ich meine sie haben
wir gesprochen über das hohner
schutzgesetz wir haben gesprochen über
den einzelplan des wirtschaftsministers
sie haben gesprochen über alles und
jedes was sie an der fortschritts
koalition schon immer gestört hat das
ist ihr gutes recht ich sage wenn sie
nicht zum justin's haushalt reden dann
müssen sie schon damit leben dass wir
das als mischung aus unserem haushalt
zum wurf werden
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen so sollte
zu recht mehrfach gesagt worden der
brutale russische angriffskrieg der
überfall auf die ukraine lässt natürlich
kein politikbereich unberührt so auch
nicht den bereich des
bundesjustizministeriums der
generalbundesanwalt ermittelt in
internationaler kooperation wegen
diverser verbrechen
wir sind uns alle einig und wissen dass
diese ermittlungen nicht morgen oder
übermorgen vielleicht auch nicht
nächstes jahr zu einer anklage führen
werden aber meine damen und herren
die geschichte hat gezeigt solche
ermittlungen führen eines tages zu
anklagen direktorin des rechtsstaates
mahlen langsam aber sie mal mit insofern
bin ich froh dass einigkeit über besteht
dass wir den generalbundesanwalt auch
mit diesem haushalt angemessen für diese
wichtige arbeit aus statt in die politik
meine damen und herren der kollege
müller hat das angesprochen wir hatten
in dieser woche rund besucher im
parlament wir hatten den justizminister
aus georgien und den justizminister der
ukraine hier zu gast aber ich muss mich
schon sehr wundern herr müller der
justizminister aus georgien hat
mitnichten davon gesprochen dass er sich
unzureichend unterstützt fühlte hatte im
gegenteil gewürdigt dass
bundesjustizminister buschmann gerade
ein kooperationsabkommen mit georgien
unterzeichnen wir begrüßen es
ausdrücklich dass wir die zusammenarbeit
im bereich des rechtsstaates stärken
weil das natürlich auch ein weg ist
georgien in die europäische union zu
verhelfen aber eher minister buschmann
wir meinen dass ein ähnliches abkommen
mit weiteren ländern mit moldauern mit
der ukraine schnell folgenlos wie
bekunden
liebe kolleginnen kollegen der krieg in
der ukraine wird mit deutscher
unterstützung hoffentlich bald enden und
danach dürfen wir die ukraine nicht
alleine lassen der aufbau der
wiederaufbau der ukraine muss sein für
uns hohe priorität haben der aufbau
eines stabilen demokratischen
rechtsstaats in der ukraine ist auch im
deutschen und europäischen interesse
die justiz ist dass es angesprochen
worden aufgabe des bundes und der länder
gemeinsam und deswegen ist es richtig
dass wir den ersten takten rechtsstaaten
und es ist richtig dass die fortschritts
koalition sich verständigt hat dass wir
ihn verstetigen und vor allem um die
digitalisierung erweitern wollen justiz
im einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert kann
nur dann akzeptanz finden wenn sie für
die bürgerinnen und bürger auch digital
erreichbar ist und wenn sie sich auch
digital gestaltet wir wollen die
vorteile der digitalisierung für die
ganze breite der justiz nutzen ohne die
nachteile zu übersehen es ist für uns
völlig klar dass wir moderne tools
nutzen wollen zur unterstützung aber es
ist auch völlig klar dass gerichtliche
entscheidung immer durch menschen
getroffen werden und nicht durch ki.ka
auch das werden wir im 21 jahrhundert
weiterhin sicherstellen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen auch das
ist ja am rande bereits angeklungen
zusätzliche stellen sind werden leider
in der justiz auch notwendig sein für
euch wieder das angesprochen weil wir
natürlich in wirtschaftlich und sozial
schwierigen zeiten leben und weil klar
ist dass wir in den kommenden monaten
mehr menschen haben werden die
rechtsschutz bei den sozialgerichten
suchen die sich an die arbeitsgerichte
wenden oder wie zum beispiel um in
mietrechtlichen rechtsschutz bekommen
sich an die zivilgerichte wenden es ist
wichtig und zentral und entscheiden dass
diese menschen zugang zum recht haben
niederschwelligen zugang und dass sie
vor allem auch schnell eine entscheidung
bekommen sozialrecht geht es nicht um
große summen aber es geht um tage um
wenige tage in denen man diese summe zur
verfügung braucht und darum ist es
wichtig dass die justiz gerade jetzt gut
aufgestellt ist um schnell den menschen
zu ihrem recht zu verhelfen
herr präsident meine damen und herren
der minister hat gesagt die fortschritts
koalition wird das familienrecht und vor
allem auch das namensrecht umfassend
modernisieren deutschland hat eines der
restriktivsten namensrechte der welt der
name ist ein wichtiger bestandteil der
persönlichkeit und das insbesondere zum
beispiel für binationale paare kaum
nachvollziehbar warum sie nahmen diese
in spanien oder auch in großbritannien
tragen dürfen in deutschland wegen des
verbots der doppelnamen wegen des
verbots von mittelnamen und ähnlichem
hier nicht führen können eine logische
sache logischen grund für diese
beschränkung gibt es nicht und auch wird
die fortschritts position sie endlich
endlich abschaffen damit den
bedürfnissen vieler menschen im land
gerecht werden ein weltoffenes und
multikulturelles land wie deutschland
braucht ein weltoffenes und
multikulturelles namensrecht vielen dank
die kollegen der cdu csu fraktion
[Applaus]
der präsident sehr geehrter
bundesminister liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen meine sehr geehrten damen und
herren ich bin beginnen mit einem zitat
aus dem vorwort des einzel plans des
bundesjustizministerium das da lautet
das haben wir heute schon gehört das
bundesministerium der justiz ist in die
erster linie ein gesetzgebungs
ministerium und es berät die anderen
ministerien bei den vorhaben
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen recht
setzen aber letztendlich wir die
abgeordneten des deutschen bundestages
wir regeln damit das zusammenleben der
menschen unser rechtsstaat gewährleistet
freiheit und schafft mit den
unabhängigen gerichten ein verfahren
dass konflikte staatlicherseits beendet
konflikte die die betroffenen selbst
nicht in den griff bekommen es verbietet
aber auch dass konflikte mit den mitteln
der selbstjustiz geregelt werden ich
hätte mir das als student in den 80er
und als richter in den 90er jahren nicht
vorstellen können dass wir irgendwann
teilweise parallel gesellschaften haben
die meinen sie könnten ihre konflikte
außerhalb des staatlichen konflikt regel
management träger der rechtsstaatlichen
kollegen überlegen der rechtsstaat muss
das alleinige gewaltmonopol haben das
sonst das vertrauen schwindet und das
vertrauen der grundsätzlich rechtstreuen
bürger und bürgerinnen unseres landes
ohne deren rechtstreue der rechtsstaat
ja gar nicht funktionieren würde leidet
aber auch wenn die die wie die
rechtsetzung die gesellschaftlichen
debatte abkürzt oder gar ersetzt und ich
habe das so empfunden bei werbeverbot
für abtreibungen und zu empfinden es
auch viele kollegen aus der justiz wenn
es um den jüngsten vorschlag des bmj
geht was eine reform der strafzumessung
vorschrift des § 146 stgb anbelangt sehr
geehrter herr minister
gesellschaftspolitik allein darf nicht
der sound sein der den ton angibt für
die rechtspolitik und die rechtsetzung
zudem sollten wir und es ist mir ein
echtes anliegen darauf achten dass wir
gesetze beschließen die sich in der
praxis dann auch als ausführbar erweisen
drei negativbeispielen aller kürze das
erste die allgemeine impfpflicht wenn
sie denn so gekommen wäre wie es ein
teil des hauses gewollt hätte wäre sie
nicht umsetzbar gewesen in der kürze der
zeit die dafür vorgesehen war weil den
krankenkassen die das machen sollten das
personal und das papier bilde die
einrichtungs bezogene impfpflicht ist
bis heute ohne wirkung geblieben wir
haben sie mit dem gemeinsamen ausschuss
vorberaten aller schnelle wegen des
schutzes
kochen bis heute ist sie praktisch
bedeutungslos geblieben sein
dazu gibt es irritationen wie ich es
gesagt habe in der justiz wenn die
rechtskontrolle zuständig sind und damit
nehme ich als ehemaliger strafrichter
jetzt die strafgerichtsbarkeit als als
beispiel das gefühl haben dass ihre
handlungsspielräume immer mehr eingeengt
werden und deshalb habe ich mir bewusst
in paragraph 46 so wie sie in
reformieren wollen noch einmal
vorgenommen die strafzumessung ist
ureigenste aufgabe der tat gerichtet das
sieht auch der bundesgerichtshof so und
greift deshalb nur bei groben fehlern
ein sie hängen aber diesen allgemeinen
rahmen der strafgerichtsbarkeit und das
addierte die gerichte haben bei der
strafzumessung immer weiter ein durch
einzelfall katalogs der vorgaben und das
fängt die befinden ist es verengt nicht
nur die befugnisse sondern das ist dass
die negative begleiterscheinung sie
erschweren damit auch die beweisaufnahme
die sich auf weitere punkte erstrecken
muss und konterkariere und damit auch
die ergebnisse die wir in der letzten
legislaturperiode mit dem damaligen
koalitionspartner gemeinsam erreicht
haben wenn es darum ging die
beweisaufnahme abzukürzen beweisantrag
rechte zu kürzen und das natürlich nicht
ohne den rechtsstaat arbeit zu beachten
und deshalb komme ich zu dem schluss
dass es richtiger wäre und so sieht es
auch der deutsche richterbund
dass wir den kurs fortsetzen den wir mit
dem pakt für den rechtsstaat gemacht
haben sie zurück so soll es ja auch sein
und im koalitionsvertrag das heißt dass
wir gemeinsam mit den ländern für
adäquate sachlichen die personelle
ausstattung der justiz der polizei
auch zum schutz vor haftungsrisiken
sorgen und insbesondere auch der
gerichte einsatz noch zu
ersatzfreiheitsstrafe alle sagen die
vorstrecken muss halbiert werden ich
regiere auf den justizminister goll der
fdp der vor über 20 jahren baden
württemberg das projekt programm
schwitzen statt sitzen angerichtet hat
warum gehen sie nicht dahingehend vor
dass ich sagen für einen tag arbeit
werden zwei tage ersatzfreiheitsstrafe
angerechnet das muss man doch
als letztes bitte noch einen satz herr
präsident vielleicht hilft es ja hilft
es ja wenn wir endlich mal begreifen
dass die menschen draußen den
bürokratischen aufwand legen wir mit den
gesetzen hier drin sein und haben uns
diesbezüglich mäßigen das ist mein
appell aber vielleicht hilft ja der
normenkontrollrat der in seinem leben
dort angesiedelt ist vielleicht nur dann
allerdings wenn man so an die ratschläge
annimmt danke schön herr
müller hatte unter anderen an dem pakt
für den rechtsstaat erinnert noch von
der großen koalition wurde damals
beschlossen 220 millionen zur verfügung
zu stellen um zusätzliche stellen bei
den staatsanwaltschaften und an
gerichten zu schaffen
und auch die ampel koalition möchte
diesen pakt verstetigen und ihn noch
erweitern um einen digital packt lustig
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident meine sehr
verehrten kolleginnen der demokratischen
fraktionen vor einigen tagen ist in
münster ein 25-jähriger trans mann
gestorben im alter wurde getötet weil es
sich am rande eines csd schützend vor
eine gruppe frauen gestellt hat malte
wurde getötet weil er den hass etwas
entgegengesetzt hat malte wurde getötet
weil vier feindlichkeit auch vor dem
leben keinen halt macht ich bin immer
noch fassungslos ich bin traurig und ich
bin maßlos
jeder menschen werden in diesem land
beleidigt angegriffen ermordet schlicht
weil sie sind wer sie sind und zu vielen
ist das immer nur noch ein
schulterzucken wert gerade deshalb ist
es mir so wichtig dass wir hier im
deutschen bundestag beim alter sprechen
darüber sprechen was gerade los ist in
unserer gesellschaft
denn wenn wir hier über unsere justiz zu
haushalt ganzen plan nur sieben
diskutieren dann sprechen wir auch immer
überreichen staatspolitik auch das
gehört zu einer haushaltsdebatte
gesprächen über das leben der menschen
in diesem land das was ich in den
letzten monaten in unserer gesellschaft
entwickelt ist kein zufall es ist kein
zufall dass hass und gewalt gerade gegen
quere und insbesondere auch gegen 21
menschen zu nehmen dann ist es verdammt
leicht gegen tiere menschen zu hetzen es
handelt sich um eine kleine
personengruppe eine personengruppe die
zwar recht verbreitet toleriert der aber
dann auch recht verbreitet mit
unverständnis begegnet wird er zwar
einmal im jahr in der regenbogenflagge
vor unserer tür und schauen sie sich
doch um wie viel mut braucht es auch
heute noch sich als queer zuordnen auch
hier im deutschen bundestag wie schwer
ist es in der wahlkreisabgeordnete nicht
das idealbild einer normalen familie zu
leben wie schwer ist es als quere
politiker hier in berlin nicht sofort
als experte für geschlechtskrankheiten
promiskuität und fetische erhalten zu
müssen
es ist dagegen so leicht zu sagen die
sollen doch lieben wen sie wollen
solange sie mich damit nicht behelligen
es dagegen so leicht über eine trans
personen zu spotten wenn man selbst nie
tief gewalt und innere konflikte über
die geschlechts erwartungen gekommenes
die die umwelt anrainer entstellt es ist
so leicht gegen trier menschen zu hetzen
weil diese personengruppen ganz allein
mit ihrer existenz so vieles infrage
gestellt was die mehrheit völlig
selbstverständlich scheint und weil es
so leicht ist nutzen reaktionäre kreise
genau diesen türöffner um einen keil in
die liberale demokratische gesellschaft
zu teilen sie fangen an trans personen
und insbesondere trans frauen als besser
wohnen darzustellen als bedrohung für
kinder für frauen als bedrohung für
einen ominösen gesunden menschenverstand
die tragen scheinbar nüchterne argumente
von frauenhäusern von sportverbänden sie
wiederholen sie so oft bis auch in der
letzten show noch von einem sachlichen
problem gerät ist von einer
meinungsverschiedenheit
das hätten wir nicht gelernt dass so
schreckliche taten die in münster das
dann in der bild -zeitung leiden landen
wenn der täter nicht deutsch oder
römisch katholisch ist als hätten wir
nicht gelernt dass sie als dann breit
diskutiert werden man minderheiten
wieder einander ausspielen kann
was dabei immer stärker in vergessenheit
gerät ist dass es eben nicht um eine
meinungsverschiedenheit geht es geht um
das existenzrecht an der ganzen
personengruppen die stück für stück in
abrede gestellt wird es geht darum die
liberale gesellschaft als ganzes infrage
zu stellen wir können diese entwicklung
doch seit einigen jahren und vielen
ländern beobachten kann es uns in die
ersten deren existenz durch angezweifelt
wird als nächstes werden frauen
abtreibungs rechte zur debatte gestellt
und das ende der rechtsstaat deswegen
ist es wichtig dass wir als
regierungsfraktionen des
selbstbestimmungsrechts einführen und
das antiquierte tsg von 1980 endlich zu
ersetzen
deswegen ist es wichtig dass wir das
abstimmungsrechte formieren weil ihre
familien in unserem rechtssystem immer
noch es ist thematisch diskriminiert
werden
und deswegen ist es wichtig dass wir
massnahmen gegen hasskriminalität
entwickeln all das ist
gesellschaftspolitischer fortschritt für
der für einige menschen unter uns von
existenzieller bedeutung ist all das
sind maßnahmen die aber für weite teile
der bevölkerung sagt durch keine
auswirkungen haben werden ihre kollegin
ich habe über malte gesprochen und über
den harz linken menschen tag für tag
ausgesetzt sind ich rufe alle dazu auf
stellen wir uns gruppenbezogene
menschenfeindlichkeit überall in den weg
wir es mal getan hat stellen wir uns
hinter den rechtsstaat nehmen wir unsere
verantwortung ganz schaffen wir land im
vielfalt vereint besser ein bauarbeiter
westend power
janka war das für die spd fraktion hat
hier unter anderem noch mal das 20 zu
allen gesetz angesprochen und das wird
schon auch länger er kritisiert dass es
für viele entwürdigend ist wenn sie im
geschlecht zustand ändern müssen unter
anderem schnyder zwei psychologische
gutachten einholen
fabian jacobi spricht jetzt für die art
die fraktion
herr präsident meine damen und herren
der haushalt des justizministeriums ist
einer der kleinsten und einer der
langweiligsten nicht aber unwichtig wäre
sondern weil er zum großen teil aus den
kosten für das personal und die
sachmittel unserer obersten gerichte
besteht und über deren notwendigkeit
lässt sich eben kaum streiten allenfalls
an kleineren einzelpunkten können sie
sich sinnvollerweise eine politische
debatte entzünden etwa wenn das
justizministerium den bereich der justiz
verlässt und auch in diesem haushalt wir
eine viertelmillion euro an eine
gesellschaftlich schädliche einrichtung
wie die antonio stiftung ausreichen will
aber das sind aspekte
interessanter als ein haushalt ist das
ministerium selbst und der geist der in
wohnt das ist in einer hierarchischen
struktur zu fördern dass der geist des
herrn ministers und also ein kluger und
philosophischer geist er zeigte sich
öffentlich etwa im februar als der herr
minister gegenüber frau maybrit illner
als lehre aus jahrtausenden
abendländischer staatsphilosophie
formulierte
der schritt zur tyrannei immer dann
getan wenn sich die inhaber der macht
selber aussuchen ob sie sich an gesetze
halten oder nicht
sie dort ändern als jüngst nun betreut
diesem motto unser kanzler nebst
reiseprogramms der maskerade sei es für
ihn genug und das infektionsschutzgesetz
in seinem luftfahrzeug nicht gar so
verbindlich da wusste man im
justizministerium auch für diese
entstandene missliche lage einen klugen
ausweg man hat die regelungen an die
sich zu halten die inhaber der macht
erkennbar nicht geneigt waren kurzerhand
abgeschafft und so ist die freiheit über
den wolken seit heute wieder etwas
grenzenloser während der masken zwang
für das buchstäbliche niedere volk am
boden fortbesteht aber das ist wasser
unter der brücke spannender der blick in
die zukunft was brütet der geist im
justizministerium weiter aus einiges
angekündigt darunter wahrlich
faszinierendes ein sogenanntes
selbstbestimmung gesetz etwa soll
folgendes vorsehen ein mensch der
objektiv in jeder für seine
umweltrelevanten hinsicht ein mann ist
jedoch für sich in anspruch nimmt eine
frau zu sein soll die macht erhalten von
allen seinen mitmenschen die aktive
bestätigung und bekräftigung dieser
unwahrheit zu verlangen und der staat so
dieses verlangen mit zwang und straff
gewalt durchsetzen es liegt mir fern den
herren minister und sein vorhaben in
religiösen kategorien fassen ihm gab
dämonische qualitäten zu sprechen zu
wollen dennoch möchte ich mit einem
klassiker zitat schließen und dieses zu
bedingten geben zitat teuflisch ist es
das reich der lüge aufzurichten und
andere menschen zu zwingen in ihm zu
leben zitat ende in diesem sinne bedanke
ich mich und wünsche weitere
erfolgreiche beratung
[Applaus]
nächste regeländerung
bündnis 90 die grünen
hier im gang also die rente liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
wir beraten den haushalt für die
für das nächste jahr und in der tat
hätte man bei dem einen oder anderen was
hier heute diskutiert wurde sich die
frage stellen können was hat es
eigentlich mit dem justiz etat zu tun
der herr brandner hat dazu wie wir es
von ihm gewohnt sind nichts beizutragen
aber in der tat liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen es gibt sehr viel zu tun und
sehr viel zu sagen im zusammenhang mit
dem justiz haushalt und in soweit freut
es mich sehr
das ist heute deutlich geworden ist dass
wir bei der ersatzfreiheitsstrafe
demnächst einen gesetzentwurf
verhandeln werden der den justiz
haushalt entlasten wird und dafür schon
mal ganz herzlichen dank lieber herr in
dem und auch sehen wie alt die sich hier
täuscht und nicht erkennen will dass das
eine relevanz im justiz haushalt hat
muss ich darstellen das ist eben so ist
dass wir in der praxis menschen haben
deren einziges problem der umstand ist
dass sie zu wenig geld haben dass sie
sich ein ticket nicht leisten können der
führt dazu dass sie geldstrafen in höhe
von 15 euro pro tag zahlen müssten die
sie nicht haben die aber im endeffekt
dazu führen dass wir bis zu 180 euro am
tag ausgeben für parkplätze in den
justizvollzugsanstalten der länder das
wollen wir ändern indem wir den
anrechnung schlüssel bei der
ersatzfreiheitsstrafe ändern liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
aber es ist auch kein geheimnis
lieber herr buschmann dass ich mir da
mehr vorstellen kann ich kann mir
vorstellen dass wir den straftatbestand
im zusammenhang mit dem fahren ohne
fahrschein so herabsetzen zu einer
ordnungswidrigkeit denn warum wird für
falsch beraten eine ordnungswidrigkeit
angesehen aber wir fahren ohne
fahrschein eine straftat das wollen wir
ändern das können wir ändern und da
hoffe ich auf ihre unterstützung diese
kolleginnen und kollegen
und überhaupt kann ich sagen
beim thema
inthronisieren gibt es noch so viel
potenzial wie wir die
staatsanwaltschaften die gerichte und
die
justizvollzugsanstalten
entlasten können ich sehe hier nicken
lieberherr justizminister
und sie alle wissen dass es eben auch
einen bereich gibt indem wir die
menschen endlich den genuss
legalisieren können von cannabis dass
wir aufhören menschen dafür zu
kriminalisieren
dass sie einen joint genießen wollen
meine damen und herren
und da es ist nämlich um zu wissen
mit diesem justizminister jemanden haben
der sich dafür einsetzt dass wir einen
weg finden
europarechtskonform legal in deutschland
die gesetze so zu verändern dass es
endlich eine realität führt dass die
menschen in meinem wahlkreis früh sein
kreuzberg und prenzlauer berg ost
tatsächlich
gleichberechtigt
genussmittel konsumieren können mit
allen anderen menschen in dieser
republik und sie haben es ja
wahrscheinlich gehört dass insbesondere
hans christian ströbele der über 20
jahre
diese mond haus angehört hat
unwahrscheinlich wie kaum ein anderer
sich für diese
gerechtigkeitsfrage
eingesetzt hat meine damen und herren
lassen sie uns doch gemeinsam den hans
christian ströbele den gefallen tun und
gemeinsam endlich das hand frei geben
meine damen und herren
als nächstes ist aber ein ziel zu setzen
sehr geehrter präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen sehr geehrter
justizminister größe und bedeutung des
einzel plans des justizministeriums
haben ja viele meiner kolleginnen und
kollegen schon hervorgehoben und gerade
im aktuellen zeitgeschehen betonen alle
demokratischen fraktionen wie wichtig
doch der rechtsstaat ist
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel hat
deshalb bereits im januar 2009 10
gemeinsam mit den ministerpräsidenten
den takt für den rechtsstaat beschlossen
sowohl die ebene als auch der umfang
zeigen wie wichtig der kanzlerin und
ihrer bundesregierung die stärkung der
justiz bundesweit gewesen ist ein großes
unterhaken aller staatlicher ebene und
lassen sie nicht mal einen satz zur
leeren bundesratsbank sagen wenn ich so
schlecht von der bundesregierung
behandelt würde würde ich mich ja auch
nicht hinsetzen zu diesem beratung
das bekenntnis des cdu-geführten
regierungen wollte die ampel koalition
eigentlich aufnehmen im
koalitionsvertrag steht dazu wörtlich
wir verstetigen mit den ländern den pakt
für den rechtsstaat und erweitern ihn um
einen digital pakt für die justiz zitat
ende seite 84 ihres gemeinsamen vertrags
falls sie das nochmal nachlesen wollen
offenbar scheint diese vereinbarung aber
keine rolle mehr für sie zu spielen
gesellschaftspolitischer sound ist ihnen
offensichtlich wichtiger verstehe ich
bei ihnen als dittsche ehrlich gesagt
auch ein bisschen aber wie würde eine
näher bekannter grünen politiker sagen
sorry i'm not convinced
denn herr minister seit wie im amt sind
es weder zum pakt für den rechtsstaat
noch zum digital packt recht etwas
passiert
der pakt für die rechtsstaat ist bis
heute ohne nachfolge und ausgelaufen
und frau kollegin sich ja jeder von
unserer fraktion weiß wie die
veranschlagung des pakts für den
rechtsstaat gelaufen ist aber egal wo er
veranschlagt ist und verortet es braucht
halt eine vereinbarung und einen pakt
und den gibt es nicht mehr das wirklich
erste ernsthafte gespräch zum thema
digital politik gibt es erst in der
kommenden woche ihre bedenken gegen eine
verstetigung des ausgelaufenen paktes
das in der bisherigen form die mittel
nicht in der justiz ankommen würden
teilen wir nicht
sie sind ausdruck eines großen
misstrauens ihrerseits gegen die länder
und vor allem wegen die
landesjustizminister
um sicher gestellt die sie führen sagt
mir ist gar nichts und schon gar nicht
im sinne eines fortschritts dass hier
mit der länder ebene fremden habe ich
schon in meiner letzten rede zeugen
letzten haushalt gesagt und schon zur
ersten justizministerkonferenz sind sie
nicht persönlich gefahren und ich weiß
nicht ob das hier die kolleginnen und
kollegen müssen auch für die nächste
justizministerkonferenz ende september
haben sie bereits abgesagt zu dieser
gemeinsamen konferenz mit den
innenministern fährt nur kollegin faeser
sie scheuen offensichtlich den kontakt
und das gespräch und diese passivität
erklärt auch warum es im bereich der
digitalisierung der justiz nicht
vorangeht
sie behaupten auch die vorschläge der
länder zu warten für die gemeinsame
digitale projekte die liegen aber ihrem
haus seit ende juli bereits vor der
justice rat hat umfangreiche kataloge
von vorschlägen gemacht und ihre
abteilung für digitales hat es auch
mitgenommen es geht um sehr konkrete
projekte die allen ebenen weiterhelfen
würden die strategie der justiz
digitaler austausch mit der polizei in
einer beweismittel cloud entwicklung
eines bundesweiten register fach
verfahrens und vieles mehr
das sind sehr viele konkrete vorschläge
der länder die jetzt aber auch zügig
angegangen umgesetzt werden müssen ich
verstehe da ins gesagt weder ihre
zögerlichkeit noch ihre verweigernde
haltung gegenüber den ländern
die beschränkung auf digitale projekte
an denen sie sich beteiligen beteiligen
wollen ist aber auch nicht das was im
koalitionsvertrag steht und was dem pakt
für den rechtsstaat verstetigen würde
ein weiterer punkt der bisher
fraktionsübergreifend vorangebracht und
unterstützt würde ist die von frau
kollegin des angesprochenen stiftung
forum recht auch ich würde gerne hier
zwei drei sätze zu sagen aus meiner
sicht kommen wir nämlich im jahr 2023 an
einen entscheidenden wendepunkt sie
schreiben diesen ansatz der stiftung aus
dem jahr 2022 schlicht fort obwohl die
stiftung 1,3 millionen euro mehr
angemeldet hat oder
1,7 vorgesehen ist immer richtungs
gesetz tatsächlich ein erheblicher
mittel aufwuchs wir waren alle in der
vorherigen regierung und in der
vorherigen fraktionsübergreifenden
beratung für die errichtung dieser
stiftung eigentlich am 1
sie herr minister und auch wir als
parlamentarier müssen schon entscheiden
ob wir diese stiftung wollen und wie wir
sie arbeitsfähig zu machen zwischen 5
millionen euro und einem mittleren
zweistelligen millionenbetrag nicht
schon ein bisschen luft und wir müssen
darüber sprechen sie befindet sich noch
im aufbau sowohl in karlsruhe als auch
in leipzig entstehen die räumlichkeiten
erst und das personal uns in der
besetzung
aber wenn es keine planungssicherheit
für die eigentlichen sachmittel gibt
dann ist ein output im sinne der
stiftung geben auch nicht möglich
wir stehen zu dieser stiftung und zu
diesem zweck das will ich an dieser
stelle noch mal deutlich sagen
ich damit zum schluss der haushalt des
bmj enthält keine entwicklung er ist ein
weiter so ohne vision und eine
vereinbarung den kollegen die eine
eingeplante die vereinbarung im
koalitionsvertrag nicht enthält sie
setzen wichtige vorhaben wie den pakt
für den rechtsstaat denn digital packt
recht und auch den aufbau der stiftung
forum recht nicht um ich erwarte mir im
laufen haushaltsberatung ein deutliches
nach steuern herzlichen dank
sagt franziska hocker man damit kommen
wir zur letzten rednerin in dieser
bundesregierung bereits vor dem
deutschen bundestag und dem bundesrat im
reichstag sowohl das deutsche bundesland
ist der kollege ist war limbach erst
wenig traktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident sehr
geehrter herr bundesminister buschmann
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen als
saarländer habe ich vor allen dingen
eines verinnerlicht nämlich den spruch
großes entsteht immer im kleinen genau
das merken wir hier in der debatte auch
rechtspolitik im bundestag ist
vielfältig und es geht trotz der
bescheidenen grösse des einzel plans 07
ums große und ganze und noch wichtiger
hier spüren wir gesellschaftliche
entwicklungen in allen lebensbereichen
direkt und unmittelbar
gespürt haben genau das auch viele
reisende in diesem sommer die an
überfüllten flughäfen standen und mit
viel verspätung oder gar nicht abgehoben
sind vielleicht liebe kolleginnen
kollegen ging es auch dem einen oder
anderen in diesem hause so was macht man
aber in so einer situation woher weiß
man welche rechte hat und was man zu tun
hat wir stellen fest der weg zum anwalt
ist für die meisten genau in so einem
moment ein viel zu hoher aufwand denn
die realität ist doch dass nur ein
bruchteil der betroffenen ihre rechte
wahrnimmt und eine entschädigung
einfordert leider muss man sagen dabei
gibt es heutzutage unternehmen
sogenannte liege tech unternehmen die
sich dieser fälle annehmen dass erfolgs
risiko übernehmen und die entschädigung
für die betroffenen einfordern das ganze
geht online und schnell und da sind wir
schon beim thema zugang zum recht und
durchsetzung von rechten es muss unser
anspruch sein liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen dass jeder mensch in
deutschland den gleichen zugang zum
recht hat und auch zur justiz an
dafür liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
müssen wir bestehende ungleichheiten
beseitigen das geht einerseits über eine
gute ausstattung der justiz das klar das
ist aber nicht der einzige punkt zugang
zum recht heißt auch sichtbare
strukturen zu schaffen die für alle
zugänglich sind so werden die jüngeren
generationen einen anderen zugang haben
und nutzen als ältere ein digital native
wird das einmal googeln wenn er oder sie
rechtliche unterstützung benötigt sie
sind vergleichsplattform gewöhnt wenn
ein termin beim arzt genug gebucht wird
mir jetzt vor allen dingen online
gemacht als legislative müssen wir genau
diese in mit entwicklungen mit bedenken
zugang zum recht heißt auch die moderne
globalisierte welt zu nutzen und unsere
fortschritts koalition liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen hat genau das verstanden
der zweite punkt der mit dem zugang zum
recht fest zusammenhängt ist die
digitalisierung das ist ein punkt der
mir persönlich aber denke ich auch ganz
vielen von uns ein besonderes anliegen
ist die digitalisierung ist sicher ein
paar breites themenfeld hier sprechen
wir einerseits über die digitalisierung
der justiz durch zum beispiel die e akte
oder des besseren informationsaustausch
zwischen behörden gerichten usw denn
digitalisierung wie der kollege vorhin
schon gesagt hat es bedeutet eben nicht
eine klage per e-mail einzureichen die
dann am gericht wieder ausgedruckt wird
genau darüber reden wir nicht liebe
kolleginnen kollegen wir sprechen aber
über moderne digitale systeme die eine
brücke schlagen zwischen der justiz der
wirtschaft und den menschen hier im land
wir haben im ersten halbjahr dieses
jahres bereits einiges geschafft das
kann man wirklich sagen als koalition
wir haben zum beispiel die virtuelle
hauptversammlungen von
aktiengesellschaften
dauerhaft geregelt in unserem
aktiengesetz und verankert wir haben
außerdem die digitalisierungs richtlinie
weiter umgesetzt und dadurch online
gründungen ermöglicht wirklich ein
besonderer schritt in deutschland das
gab es vorher in dieser form nicht das
sind wichtige schritte und jetzt müssen
wir genau hier weitermachen um als
wirtschaftsstandort und starker
rechtsstaat weiter erfolgreich sein zu
können müssen wir schon heute die
grundlagen legen für digitale strukturen
das sehen wir gerade an dem beispiel
regel tag hier liegt wirklich
unglaublich viel potenzial und wir
dürfen uns nicht abhängen lassen und
eine entwicklung verpassen die weltweit
passiert liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
digitalisierung und zugang zum recht das
müssen wir immer zusammen denken sie
bedingen sich gegenseitig und hängen
voneinander ab sie sind die grundlage
für künftige rechtsstaatlichkeit in
deutschland deswegen ist dieser haushalt
auch so wichtig es geht nicht bloß um
mittel für die justiz es geht um nichts
anderes als um den erhalt unserer
rechtsstaatlichkeit und damit auch
unseres demokratischen systems
doch noch wie es möchte ich mich
herzlich bedanken
einen kollegen und kollegen die an
diesem haushalt gearbeitet haben ganz
besonders an und bei unserer bricht der
stadt da es sei dies ja ich freue mich
auf die weiteren beratungen vielen dank
esra limbacher war hier der letzte
redner zum einzelplan 7 der etat für das
justizministerium ist das kleinste
budget allerdings in der bandbreite der
themen wohl dann das vielfältigste denn
das justizministerium hilft ja den
anderen ministerien bei der vorbereitung
für andere
rechtsgutachten und